the final tally counted and Peter Lim
jaronrat leader of the move forward
party is 51 votes short his Coalition of
eight parties has a clear majority in
the lower house
but under Thailand's military drafted
Constitution the Prime Minister has to
be elected with a combined vote from the
lower house and the mostly
military-appointed Senate but I'm not
giving up I'm going to strategize once
again how to consolidate voice just to
make sure that we reach 376
some Senators site to move forwards plan
to reform a law that prohibits insults
against the monarchy as the main reason
why they would not vote for Peter it is
very simple senators are not the problem
it's up to Peter and his party whether
they will continue to go against the
monarchy if so it will be a conflict
between them and the Senators
critics say the law has been used mostly
to silence dissent against the
government
outside Parliament Peter supporters
Gavin many stayed on long after the vote
had been counted people here say they
came to
him
and some even say to ignore the will of
the people
the election commission has asked the
Constitutional Court to disqualify Peter
on grounds that he owned shares in a
media company in violation of Thai
election laws
the court is also looking into whether
the party's plan to amend the laws
relating to the monarchy amount to an
attempt to overthrow the government
since the king is Thailand's head of
state it's not clear yet if these
protests will lead to larger Street
demonstrations as they have in the past
as for Peter and his Coalition the next
few days will be crucial he will try to
keep on voting and the negotiation uh
you know with the MPS which are on the
opposition side and the negotiation with
the Senators has to be much more you
could say rigorous as it has been in the
past couple of weeks legislators are due
to hold a new vote for prime minister
next Wednesday Florence Louis Al Jazeera
Bangkok
the Philippine Capital Manila is facing
major